hey everybody it's Mike freder here with
on call compliance Solutions and I'm
back with another compliance tip of the
week this week we're talking about cmmc
control cm. L2
d349 control and monitor user installed
[Music]
software say hey if you're a defense
contractor is feeling overwhelmed tired
and alone trying to understand all of
this cmmc DS and nist sp17 compliance
stuff on top of an already uh colossal
workload well I've got great news for
you you found your home here at on call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's on
call compliance Hero Let's jump into it
so on cmmc control cm.
l234 do9 control and monitor user
installed software we come face to face
with the reality of best it management
practices you should not be allowing
your users to install anything they want
on their systems not your CEO not your
CFO not your coo not your floor line
users nobody okay in fact you really
shouldn't let them install anything that
you don't approve in an ideal situation
and apparently these nist requirements
mandate this practice be put into place
so now you have a real excuse to go back
and explain why this has to be put in
place because you have to by law at the
end of the day viruses spyware are
typically a result of systems where the
installation of virtually anything is
possible and software is not monitored
again it's really tough to install a
virus if it requires an ad an IT admin's
approval to keep system secure you must
be doing both let's take a look at what
the assessors are looking for on this
one so three things they're looking for
uh one determine if a policy specifying
whether white listing or black listing
is to be implemented uh and is specified
implemented so again if we were to sort
of give a sample answer here we would
say Hey look it's implemented via uh
permit by exception Group Policy so
again you can set up group policy
to make it so that you can't install
software without an escalation to an
administrative account uh endpoint
management solution so again you can use
an endpoint management solution that
restricts the installation of software
uh and so we might say endpoint
management solution also denies
malicious or unauthorized software
execution uh and then we can say our
firewall also does this too right our
firewall rules and virus policies do not
allow uh any malicious programs to be
installed or to pass through the
firewall in terms of of traffic that's
unauthorized now the second Point uh
that they're looking for is determine if
the software allowed to execute under
Whit listing or denied use under
blacklisting is specified uh so here
we'll answer software which is allowed
to execute is specified in the
organization's Baseline configuration
and network inventory documentation so
again in our documentation we're going
to talk about the software itself uh
that is allowed under white listing or
again deny all by blacklisting so this
is where your software inventory comes
into place you know you're supposed to
have that in your system security plan
and accompanying documentation and again
it's mandated here and determine if
weight listing to allow the execution of
authorized software or blacklisting to
prevent the use of unauthorized software
is implemented as
specified uh that's the third point so
if we were to answer that we'd say hey
implemented via permit by exception
Group Policy endpoint management
solution also denies malicious or
unauthorized software execution so again
description of how it gets done now hey
at on call we work with defense
contractors just like you who have had
this stars nist itar and cmmc compliant
stuff dropped into their laps like a
seagull on a sunny day we teach you how
to level up and be a proper on call
compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps gray areas and getting
this all solved while showing you how to
leverage compliance as your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on call compliance hero can
do for you if you're looking for more
help getting compliant our compliance
experts are always on call for you visit
cmmc compliance secrets.com again cmmc
compliance secrets.com
or check out the bio below for links to
get help right now and if you love the
content we're putting out here for you
help us out with a big thumbs up on that
like button or even better smash the
Subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance nerds roll it out until next
compliance tip my friends stay safe and
secure out there and hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance I'll
see you on the next one
[Music]